[Music]
greetings to my 3abn family and welcome
to another 3abn today Bible Q&A my name
is Ricky Carter and I'll be your host
glad that you can be with us today we've
got another hour packed program with
your Bible questions and you know what
we've got the answers right here in the
word of God Amen we'll be sharing them
with you let me introduce you to our
panel to my right I have sister Shelley
Quinn welcome sister Shel such a
blessing once again we want to thank you
for your question questions and for your
participation in this program amen amen
and next to her we have my brother
Daniel pin welcome sir good good to be
here glad glad to be able to take this
time with you and talk about God's word
amen amen and next to him via Skype we
have Pastor James rafy welcome Pastor
James good to be here Ricky thanks for
the invite and good to join you all on
the set with the 3abn Bible Q&A looking
forward to this time together amen amen
oh before we get into the questions why
don't we start off with a word of prayer
brother Daniel could you bless us with
prayer please our loving Heavenly Father
Lord it is our privilege to say what
does the Bible say yes then we listen to
your words and we ask for your Holy
Spirit to tune our ears in to be able to
not only hear and understand but then to
go out changed walking according to your
path and so for this hour in all of our
Lives dear God we ask that you fill us
with the Holy Spirit here on this set in
this room and wherever these words are
heard in Jesus name I pray amen amen
amen all right well shall I've got your
first question but before I give that to
you I want to share with our viewers at
home how you can participate with Bible
Q&A well one of the first ways you can
do is you can email us you can send an
email to Bible QA 3abn TV that's Bible
QA 3bn
dotv or you could text text us to 618
3975 that's 618 228
3975 or for those of you who are on
Instagram you can send us your questions
that way to at 3abn official at 3abn
official and have you heard about our
website 3abn Bible
answers.com we've got a great website
where you can get your Bible answers
right there as well you can get answers
to questions like what happens when you
die questions on health questions on the
Judgment so check out that website 3abn
Bible ansers.com all right sister Shell
got your first question
okay Daniel 12: 2 specifies two kinds of
resurrections can you please explain to
people the difference and how important
it is to understand it furthermore
please clarify ify if Revelation 1:7
supports the idea of only two
resurrections just like Daniel 12:2 says
if not please explain if there is
another kind of Resurrection based on
Revelation 1:7 can we call this a
special Resurrection lastly if there is
a special Resurrection for the wicked is
there also a special Resurrection for
the righteous where can we find it in
the Bible and that was emailed to us
thank you for that question I would
direct you first to John 5: 28 and 29
where Jesus sayso not Marvel at this for
the hour is coming in which all who are
in the graves will hear his voice and
will come forth those who have done good
to the resurrection of life and those
who have done evil to the resurrection
of
condemnation the resurrection to life
are the deceased Believers are raised
when first the Thessalonians 4:16 And1
17 says he descends with a shout with
the voice of the Archangel and the dead
in Christ will rise first then we who
are alive and remain will be caught up
together to meet him in the air and will
always be with him this is when 1
Corinthians 15:52 through 55 says we are
put on
immortality now Revelation 20:
5-6 describes the resurrection of the
righteous as the first resurrection it
says Revelation
25-6 this is the first resurrection see
it's the righteous blessed and holy is
he who has part in the first
resurrection over such the second death
has no power but they shall be Priests
of God and Christ and shall reign with
him a thousand years so the two general
resurrections you've got the the first
resurrection of the righteous now what's
the second Resurrection Revelation 25
says the rest of the Dead did not live
until the end of the Thousand Years so
the resurrection of the unrighteous they
come up in the resurrection of
condemnation they go before the Lord the
great white Throne judgment and then
they are sent to the Lake of Fire where
they perish now Daniel 12:2
says many of those who sleep in the dust
of the earth doesn't say all many of
those who sleep in the dust of the Earth
shall awake some to everlasting life
some to shame and contempt so let's look
at special resurrections some to
everlasting life Matthew 27 52- 53
following Jesus crucifixion there was a
special resurrection of some faithful
Saints it says the tombs broke open the
bodies of many holy people who had that
died were raised to life they came out
of the tombs after Jesus resurrection
they went into the holy city and
appeared to many people Revelation 1:7
that you ask about behold he is coming
with clouds every ey will see him even
they who pierced him and all the tribes
of the earth will mourn because of him
this clearly implies that those
responsible for the death of Christ will
be Resurrected to witness his coming and
I'm out of
time thank you sister very good all
right brother Daniel got your first
question did unicorns exist before the
current ERA all right there are several
references in the Bible explaining that
they are strong have a horn and run in
bands they can be Haring when they're
young they skip and when they're full
grown they run like
Bulls there are nine verses in the Old
Testament about this but they are
considered mythical in our time did they
once exist and that was emailed to us
all right now as a high school Bible
teacher every year maybe a little more
often somebody would come and say hey Mr
parent did you know there are unicorns
in the Bible so this question needs to
be answered now the word unicorn simply
means one horn and there are animals
that have one horn so here's your little
nature segment for the day you've got
the Indian rhinoceros the Latin name is
rhinoceros unicornus which means sharp
one horn on the nose okay there's the
SAA otherwise called the spindle horn or
the Asian unicorn there's the rhino
beetle the Rhino horned lizard the ca
beautiful bird that is not technically a
unicorn but people categorize it there
and then in the sea there's the unicorn
fish and the Narwhal I might have missed
something there but the word unicorn
appears in the King James version nine
times it's the Hebrew word reim
the translation unicorn might have come
from the Septuagint monocerus or from
the Latin Vulgate unicornus both of
those meaning one horn now it definitely
is not referring to the mythical
creature uh of fantasy thoughts like
that those mythical unicorns have not
existed now the new King James version
along with many other translations refer
to it as the wild ox now there were
domestic oxen and there are wild oxen
just like there are domestic donkeys and
wild donkeys and we find a similar word
actually in another ancient language
Acadian that refers to a also a wild
horned Ox there were the Oro and the
Urus those were wild large uh large wild
cattle that roamed Asia in the near East
uh extinct for a little more than 400
years now but they weren't one horned
animals but if we go to Deuteronomy
33:17 looking at one of those instances
of that R aim it refers to the horns of
the Unicorn it's a singular unicorn then
horn horns of the Unicorn so uh there we
have an indication that maybe it was a
two-horned beast so whether it was one
horned or two horns it really doesn't
matter the issue that is being uh
brought out in the references to this
animal is that you have an animal of
strength and power job 39:9 and10 speaks
of it as being Untamed untamable by man
in numbers 23:22 and 24 ver8 God uses
that animal to describe his own strength
so when you come across if you're
reading the King James version when you
come across a unicorn picture something
that is strong Mighty and cannot be
tamed by any person but you don't
necessarily and you shouldn't see some
rainbow colored horse bounding through
the disguise with a horn coming out its
nose thank you brother thank you very
much for that all right Pastor James
I've got your first question here we
go I believe that between the encounter
of Mary and then Thomas Jesus went to
heaven to get God's approval for his
sacrifice on the cross Hebrews 9:12
talks about this but some translations
say that Jesus went to the holy place
and others say that he went to the most
holy place which compartment in the
Heavenly Sanctuary did Jesus go to and
that was sent to us from Carlos in
Pennsylvania by
email thank you Carlos from Pennsylvania
you know the Bible doesn't actually
teach that Jesus went into the most holy
place of the Heavenly Sanctuary at his
Ascension and then we know know this for
at least three reasons the immediate
context of Hebrews the original Greek
meaning of the words translated Most
Holy place in the book of Hebrews and
then the larger context of the Bible so
let's just take a look the immediate
context of Hebrews in Hebrews 9 1-5 we
find a description of the Holy place and
the most holy place of the Earthly
Sanctuary which was a type of the
Heavenly Sanctuary where Christ is the
high priest now Paul's intent here
throughout the remainder of this chapter
is to direct us and especially in the
book of Hebrews from the Earthly type to
the Heavenly reality note the closing
thought in verse five of Hebrews 9
speaking of the most holy place of which
we cannot now speak particularly or in
detail the new King James says in other
words the rest of this chapter does not
speak in detail of the most holy place
but rather of the sanctuary as a whole
Paul's Point here is to move the Hebrews
the Jews from the Earthly to the
heavenly to show that Christ is in the
Heavenly Sanctuary his concern was not
to prove what part of the Heavenly
Sanctuary Jesus was ministering in but
rather to help them understand that the
Heavenly replaces the Earthly so we do
disservice to these scriptures when we
attempt to make them say something that
the Holy Spirit never intended for them
to say now the original Greek again Paul
is translating the original Greek his is
speaking in the original Greek so his
hearers are hearing him say
this Earthly Sanctuary was a type of the
Heavenly sanctuary and the Earthly
Tabernacle is is now the Heavenly
reality rather than a specific location
the the most holy place is described in
verse 5 and the Greek says it is hagon
hagon holiest of all holiest hagon all
hagon that phrase hagon hagon describing
the most holy place is never used again
in the book of Hebrews uh so verse 5 is
the only place that is used and it is a
reference to the Earthly Sanctuary not
the Heavenly Sanctuary but again Paul is
transitioning us to the Heavenly
Sanctuary so his point his intent is to
get us from the Earthly to the Heavenly
he uses the Earthly to describe the two
apartments and then he goes to the
Heavenly to tell us basically that Jesus
Christ is in the holiest that's what it
says in verse 8 that word is rendered
sanctuary in the new revised Standard
Version it's hagon in the Greek so it's
not really talking about the most holy
place
the holiest in the sense that it is the
Heavenly Sanctuary not the Earthly
Sanctuary uh this is clearly IND
indicated by his stating that the way
into the sanctuary in heaven was not yet
made manifest while the Earthly type was
still standing all the Earthly
sanctuaries the one that Moses built the
one that uh Solomon built and the one
that was standing when Jesus came they
were patterned after the sanctuary of
the true Tabernacle in heaven the
holiest of all the sanctuaries or
temples which is the Heavenly one that's
Paul's point point in Hebrews chap 11 so
these Earthly types uh were made Holy by
God's presence but the sanctuary in
heaven is the holiest of all because
it's the very Dwelling Place of God now
I like the way the King James translates
uh Hebrews 9:12 it says but by his own
blood he entered in once into the holy
Place having obtained Eternal Redemption
for us the King James is the most
accurate the ESV the ASV the nasv the
RSV all render a pretty fair trans
transl ation though it's somewhat
different he entered once into the holy
places not by the means of blood of
goats and calves etc etc the NIV and the
new King James are the only translations
that really fall short and mislead they
use the most holy place that he entered
into the most holy place that is not in
the Greek it's not supported by the
Greek and it's really not supported by
Paul's argument or his point in the book
of Hebrews and especially in Hebrews
chapter n wow amen amen thank you very
much for that detailed answer all right
sister Shell I have your second question
I feel like God is ignoring me or maybe
I'm just very far away from him I have
been praying to feel the presence of God
or hear him but I don't hear or feel him
I want to have a close relationship with
him please help me what should I do
that's from Annabelle in the UK who
emailed that to us Annabelle bless you
baby girl I'll tell you what you know
you know prayer is what cultivates our
relationship with the Lord amen prayer
you could say communicating with the
Lord
communication is the relationship make
it a two-way prayer where you're praying
to God let him speak to you through his
word while you're praying and listen for
him I wrote a book called pressing into
his presence because I struggled like
you did to really come into the presence
of the Lord and and I wanted to be so
close to him in what he showed me I
don't believe in formulas but there was
a pattern to the prayer that God led me
as I was seeking him and that was to
First enter into his gates with praise
and thanksgiving is Psalm 10 verse4 says
if we start thanking God for everything
and we're praising him for who he is
when we are the the Bible says in Psalm
22:3 God inhabits the Praises of his
people it's something that you can be in
a down in the mouth attitude you start
praising the Lord and you know what he
just kind of lifts you and and you feel
him there now repentance was the second
part god taught me to because I know
he's not going to listen to me unless
I've got a clean hands and a clean hard
so Isaiah 59:2 says your iniquities have
separated you from God your sins have
hidden his face from you so that he will
not hear is there anything in the way
ask God that if there's something that
maybe you're holding on to then remember
first John 1:9 that says if we confess
our sins he's faithful and just to
forgive us our sins now an interesting
thing God taught me after praise and
repentance was affirmation what do I
mean pray the word of God back to him
I'll tell you praying his word deepens
your relationship with him I make that
part of my Thanksgiving I'm thanking him
you know I say thank you Lord I know
that all have sinned and fallen short of
the glory of God but I thank you Lord
that by your grace it says that all sin
falls short of the glory of God but
through Christ Jesus and the Redemption
that is him we are freely justified by
the grace of God
hallelujah now walk in obedience to his
word John
14:23 listen to what Jesus said John
14:23 if anyone loves me he will keep my
word that means not just to store it in
your heart or your head but that you are
walking in obedience to the word and my
father will love him and we will come to
him and make make our home with him
Worship the Lord in the beauty of
Holiness this is one way that you are
coming closer to him another thing is
remember what Jesus said in Matthew 18
3-4 we've got to be converted and become
like little
children and he says nobody's even going
to get into the kingdom unless they do
so that means we are fully dependent
upon him and Romans 8 chapter or verses
15 and 16 Paul Paul says we didn't
receive the spirit of fear but the
spirit that cries out ABA father so we
come boldly before the throne of grace
in Hebrews
4:16 Hebrews 13 Jesus God promises I
will never leave you or forsake you and
we can boldly say the Lord is my helper
what can man do to me but here Annabelle
is the final thought Psalm
46:10 God says be still quit striving
don't go by feelings he says know that I
am God I will be exalted I will be
exalted in your life trust the Lord
trust that he's there with you practice
his presence talk to him throughout the
day and just thank him that he's there
with you he is whether you feel it or
not amen amen communication is key M
brother Daniel here's your second
question can you explain the
significance of the 12 tribes of Israel
that's from Georgette and she sent that
to us via Instagram all right thank you
Georgette uh let's look at those 12
tribes and start with this God God gives
the gospel message to a family and then
that family is to share the message that
God gives them and the gospel message is
this God invites us to join his family
uh Romans 5 deals with that we're in the
the family of Adam the consequences of
sin and invited into the family of
Christ let's look at this family of 12
tribes that we were introduced to at the
final chapters of the Book of Genesis
and then all the way through the Bible
even to the last book of the Bible we
find the tribes of Israel God made a
promise to Abraham in Genesis 12 verse
1:3 in that promise it says in you all
the families of the Earth shall be
blessed all right so your family then is
going to have a blessing that extends to
other families to other places of the
earth that promise was reconfirmed to
Abraham uh given also to his son Isaac
and then confirmed again to Isaac's
younger of his twin Sons Jacob uh in
Genesis 28:13 to15 we find almost the
same words here in you and your seed all
right through your family all the
families of the Earth shall be blessed
so through this family we're going to
find blessings to the world now Jacob
had 12 sons he had six through his wife
Leah two through Rachel two two more
through one of their servants Bila and
two more through another servant zilpa
these men uh grew and as they grew they
be their families became the 12 tribes
of Israel coming from those 12 sons of
Jacob and then the TW tribes of Israel
are God's family in the Old Testament
looking forward to the promise of Jesus
now each of these men and their
descendant subsequently uh you know they
pass on their traits and so they develop
characteristics that we find scattered
all sorts of different places throughout
the Bible I'll mention just a few of
them right here uh in the naming of the
children in Genesis 29: 30 to 3 29 and
30 and then chapter 35 each of those
names means something that speaks about
the character of not only these men but
the tribes that come after them we have
Genesis 49 where Jacob blesses his sons
and those blessings tell us about these
uh these tribes Moses blesses the tribes
in Deuteronomy chapter 33 in Numbers
Chapter 2 And1 The tribal placement
around the Tabernacle and in the
marching orders actually speaks a little
bit about what these tribes were let me
let me share with you a couple of uh
specific tribes the Levites Exodus 32
are separated for service in the temple
as priests 1 Chronicles 20: 32 and 33 I
love these verses here because of the
insight into a small group of people
says of the sons of issachar that's one
of the tribes there who had under
understanding of the times to know what
Israel ought to do well here's here's a
tribe who they apparently were were good
at at recognizing what God's
instructions were and then it speaks of
zebulun 50,000 of them went to battle
experts in war with all weapons and then
we learn about the tribe of Dan that
caused an apostasy and his name is
actually excluded from The Book of
Revelation the tribe of Judah willing to
die for the the life of his brother
Benjamin we discover though he'd
actually betrayed his brother Joseph uh
seemingly into death earlier through
Judah the the Messiah comes but the
point is this each of these tribes are
different representing aspects of
character and then we are invited into
God's family and when we receiveing the
full promise enter into the New
Jerusalem there are 12 gates and on
those gates are the names each one
representing one of the tribes of Israel
well which gate are you going to go into
you're not just going to go wherever you
want you're going to go where God leads
you which means that when we enter into
God's family each one of these different
tribes reveals that our process of
overcoming through the grace of God is
is going to be unique and say my name's
Daniel and maybe I will go no not
through the tribe of Dan they're not
there I don't know I might go in through
the gate of Simeon whatever whatever
trial Simeon and their tribe goes
through I go through that as well and
it's all through Christ so God invites
us into the family to participate in the
sharing of and living out the gospel
message amen amen thank you sir thank
you all right Pastor James here's your
second
question if God will not forgive me if I
don't forgive someone else yet if I
confess confess my sins he is faithful
and just to forgive me how does that
work can I confess my sins and still not
forgive someone else seemed like a
contradiction yet I know it is not
that's from Suzanne who emailed that to
us
that is such an important question
Suzanne thank you for that question
you're referring to Matthew chapter 6:
14 and 15 where it says if you forgive
not men their trespasses neither will
your heavenly father forgive you uh
excuse me if you forgive men their
trespasses your heavenly father will
also forgive you but if you forgive not
men their trespasses neither will your
heavenly father forgive your trespasses
and it's really not that God will not
forgive us if we don't forgive others I
don't think that's the message that's
being communicated in the Bible Old and
New Testament our lack of forgiveness to
others is actually an evidence that we
have not received the Forgiveness of God
to us so the more we are forgiven the
more we actually forgive and the more
self-righteous we become the less we
feel the need for God's forgiveness and
therefore the less forgiving we become
toward others and we see this
Illustrated in the story of the servant
who owed his master a great debt now
this story is found in Matthew chapter
18 we won't have time to read the verses
but here's the basic summary of the
story the man was brought in before his
Lord to give an account for all the debt
that he owed and when it was found that
he owed this great debt and he couldn't
pay it back it was ordered that he and
his his whole family should be sold or
put in jail until the debt be paid and
the man said to the master give me time
and I will pay you everything well at
that point the the king the master the
lord of the servant basically says he
has compassion on him and he forgives
him the whole debt and that man leaves
there and he finds a fellow servant who
owes him a small little debt compar in
comparison to the debt he's just been
forgiven and he takes that servant by
the throat and he says pay me all that
you owe me and the servant asks him the
same thing that he asks his Lord give me
time and I'll pay you everything and he
wouldn't do it and he put him in jail
until his debt was paid and so when the
people heard about this they reported it
back to the Lord and he brought him in
and he said hey you know I forgave you
that great debt and uh you couldn't even
forgive that little debt and he took the
whole account put it back into his
account and he was um sold and his
family were put in jail uh because he
was unwilling to forgive his the debt
that was owed to him as the Lord had
forgiven him and that's the point of the
story when we realize how much God has
forgiven us what a pittance it is what a
small thing it is for us to forgive
others so when we're truly forgiven of
God we feel the Forgiveness of God and
we know the Forgiveness of God we will
forgive others if we don't we'll be like
that servant he asked for time to pay
his Lord back and when he left there
even though he had been forgiven he
didn't realize that forgiveness he
thought he had time and so he went out
to try to get the money that he owed to
his Lord rather than basking in the
Forgiveness that was granted to him the
grace of God that was granted to him and
it's the same with us we will either
think we will either have a covenant
relationship with God where we think we
have to earn salvation and pay him back
or we'll have the New Covenant
relationship with him where we are saved
by his grace and we become channels of
Grace toward others now remember if you
find you can't forgive someone Jesus
Christ says that he is faithful to
forgive us our sins and also to cleanse
us from all unrighteousness give your
heart to God ask him to give you that
forgiveness because that forgiveness
toward others is a gift from God amen
amen thank you sir all right sister Shel
I have your third question but before I
give that to you I want to remind our
viewers at home how they can participate
with 3abn today Bible Q&A one of three
ways you can email us your questions to
Bible QA 3abn.org
official at 3 abnor
official all right Shelly question
number three in talking to Jesus the
rich man asked what was needed to go to
heaven Jesus plainly states to follow
the Commandments but later when he asked
what he was missing Jesus said for him
to sell his possessions and follow him
when he walked away sad Jesus said most
rich people would not be going to heaven
did Jesus condemn the rich man does it
require more than following the Ten
Commandments as the minimum that's from
Michael who email that to us Michael
thank you for your question in John 3:17
Jesus said God did not send his son into
the world to condemn the world but that
the world through him might be saved so
the answer to your question is no he did
not the answer to the rest of your
question is
more required than mere moral out moral
obligation to com keep his Commandments
is more required yes what moral it's
eternal life is not attained through
adherence to God's Commandments it is
attained through a heartfelt commitment
and relationship with Jesus Christ so
what we see here we've got this
interaction in mark Mark chapter
10 and the young rich man comes to Jesus
in verse 17 and he says good teacher
what must I do to be saved so he's
recognizing Jesus as a respected teacher
he's got obviously an interest in
eternal life Jesus directs him to God
saying hm why do you call me good
because only God is good so he's trying
to get him to think about who he's
talking to and then Jesus goes into
beginning to list some of the Ten
Commandments and you know what the Young
Rich Man does he goes hey man I've done
that since I was a little boy he was
confident of his moral of being morally
upright and Jesus knew that this man's
problems was that he loved money that he
was storing up Treasures on Earth so
Jesus says to
him he's challenging him when he said
sell everything you have give it to the
poor and then you'll have treasure in
heaven here's his challenge come follow
me but the young man that was
crestfallen he walks away sad because
money had become his Idol and he had
much of it so when Jesus says that those
who are wealthy he uses a hyperbolic
statement saying it's easier for the
camel to go through the eye of a needle
than for a rich man to make it into
heaven and you know what the people are
saying wait a minute I thought riches
were a blessing from God if they can't
be saved who can be saved Jesus says
with man this is impossible but With God
all things are possible salvation
belongs to God it is his Divine act to
justify us it is his Divine work to
sanctify us amen amen thank you sister
all right Daniel here's your third
question how are public and private
worship connected that's from Andrew all
right thank you good question Andrew and
I want to share just a couple of
examples to start with think of a boat
in the water you got the above part of
the boat above water part of the boat
that's visible then you got the below
water part of the boat which is
invisible same boat all right but you're
seeing it in different ways you got this
piece of paper here two sides of the
paper but can you separate them they're
they're they're intimately connected you
cannot have one side without having the
other side you always have both of them
together and that's the way it is with
worship as well public and private there
is only worship worship is how you live
your life submitting to God in all
things public or private just submitting
to God that's what it is so there are
worshipful activities that you may
engage in only in public and there are
engage in only in private but they're
just different glimpses above water or
below water of worship amen and we see
the same thing exhibited in
relationships as well uh think about
relational Intimacy in marriage there
are words that you would Express to the
one you love only in private no other
ear should hear them but then there are
other words of praise and adoration that
it's important to demonstrate in public
uh how much you love the one who you've
given your life to and there are certain
things in worship that are like that
that be belong only to the ear of God
you can't tell another person certain
Praises so deep from the heart and
confession and in honesty that you can't
share with another individual and I
think about this with Matthew 66 When
you pray go into your room and when you
have shut your door pray to your father
who is in the secret place and your
father who sees in secret will reward
you openly and then I love this text
here this promise in Matthew 2:17 to him
who overcomes I will give some of the
Hidden Mana to eat and I will give him a
white stone and on the stone a new name
written which no one knows except him
who receives it something that is only
between you and God so intimate and
private God's relationship with you is
such that there's no other person alive
you're the only one I mean that is that
is close and you can't share those
things with anybody else so here's the
relationship here's how I put it
together private worship private worship
alone gives substance to your public
worship and public worship gives
expression to your private worship if
you don't have the private worship then
there's nothing to express publicly and
if you don't express publicly what's
going on inside then what's going on
inside is not really really real each
one of them uh is United and they
strengthen each other so we want to say
Lord help me to be honest and sincere
and active in both of those areas of my
life of worshiping you both privately I
got to have those moments and publicly
letting everybody know how I feel about
you amen amen thank you for that answer
beautiful all right Pastor James here's
your third question did Jesus preached
to the people in hell when he was buried
1 Peter 3:19 and 20 and that's from
Norma in Florida who texted that to
us great question Nar from Florida
there's been a lot of misunderstanding
regarding these verses of scripture over
the years you know in the 1990s while
doing evangelism in the country of
Pakistan a Methodist Pastor who is
becoming an Adventist shared these
verses with me from the eru Bible and
they actually translated purgatory and
in in the verse so in other words the
translation taught that Christ descended
to some place called Purgatory to preach
the souls uh that were in limbo now this
is not what the text is actually saying
the best way that we can understand this
verse is to break it down Point by point
and then look at how the Bible helps us
to understand it so let's do that by
beginning with Verse 18 notice what it
says for Christ also has suffered for
sins the just for the unjust that he
might bring us to God being put to death
in the flesh but quickened by the Spirit
by which also he went and preached now
let's stop there for just a
second first we should notice how Christ
preached to those Spirits in prison he
did it by the spirit and that word is
capitalized in the Bible that means it
is referring to the holy spirit so
whatever Christ did in preaching during
this time he did it through the Holy
Spirit now let's ask the question when
was the preaching done the answer is
given in verse 20 when Once the
longsuffering of God waited in the days
of Noah while the ark Was preparing
where in few that is in eight Souls were
saved by water so the preaching was
actually done while the Ark was being
built during the preaching of Noah to
the anti- deluvian world now one more
question to whom was the preaching done
the text says unto Spirits in prison
which sometimes were disobedient
throughout the Bible we find this
terminology used in describing those who
were Bound in the prison House of sin
David actually prayed in um Psalm 142
verse 7 bring my soul out of prison that
I may praise Thy Name Jesus said in Luke
4:18 the spirit of the Lord is upon me
because he has anointed me to proclaim
the good news to the poor he has sent me
to Proclaim freedom for the prisoners
and recovery of sight for the blind to
set the oppressed free and that's the
NIV and of course Isaiah 426 and 7 says
I have called excuse me I the Lord have
called thee in righteousness and I will
hold thy hand I will keep thee for and I
will give thee for a covenant of the
people for a light to the Gentiles to
open the blind eyes to bring out the
prisoners from prison and them that sit
in darkness out of the prison house and
that's a prophecy of Christ uh the
Covenant Keeper in Isaiah 42:6 so the
Apostle Paul even described this
experience in his words he said that the
the law of sin and death was bringing
him into captivity to the law of sin in
in Romans 7: 24 and just a few verses
later Paul described how he was made
free from this captivity or prison House
of sin by the power of the holy spirit
in Romans 81 and2 so what the Bible is
saying here is simply that Christ
through the Holy Spirit was present
while they were preached Christ was
there through the Holy Spirit to speak
conviction to the hearts and appeal to
those who are in the prison House of sin
and you have to read into the text
something that's not biblical to come to
the conclusion that Christ was preaching
to Spirits in some disembodied place
called Purgatory that's not in the Bible
it's not in the text except maybe in the
erdu translation so there are three
questions that are clearly answered in
the text itself that Christ preached by
the Holy Spirit number one number two
that he did it while the ark Was
preparing and number three he did it to
the spirits in prison or those anti
delians whose sinful lives had bound
them in the prison House of sin and
that's what the Bible teaches that's how
this verse is explained according to the
scriptures wonderful wow very good thank
you for that great answer all right
sister Shell got your fourth and final
question okay can you please explain
what Covenant keeping Covenant keeping
means that's from Marlo in Washington
who texted that to us Marlo this is such
a wonderful question and I thought it
would be simple to answer but here's
there's so much I'd like to say that it
wasn't I want to direct you to the 3abn
series called spotless the Everlasting
Covenant there 17 programs on the
Covenant of God and what it means to be
a covenant keeper or there is a book
called spotless experiencing the
Everlasting Covenant through
righteousness by faith that is available
through 3abn when we're speaking of
keeping Covenant we're speaking of the
Everlasting Covenant and God introduced
that in Genesis 3:15 and it doesn't
conclude until the end of revelation we
enter into Covenant relationship by
accepting Christ as our savior at which
point the first aspect of righteousness
by faith we're Justified but there's
more we have to accept him as Lord we
have to receive both of the aspects of
righteousness by faith and then we are
then
Sanctified through righteousness by
faith God works in us to Will and to do
his good pleasure to keep Covenant means
to remain in Christ to abide in Christ
Jesus said in John 155 and 6 I am the
vine you are the branches he who abides
in me and I in him will bear much fruit
but without me you can do nothing you
know we can't even obey except by the
grace of God because it is God who works
in us to Will and to do his good purpose
he says if anyone doesn't abide he's
cast out and he's like a branch he's
withered and then at the end of time
they're gathered
into and uh gathered by the angels and
thrown into the fire and burned so I
love what first John 2:6 says because I
think it explains abiding he who abides
in Christ when we're in Christ when
we're part of his body we are submitted
to him and it says he who abides must
also himself walk as he walked what does
he mean we're walking in total
dependence God as as Jesus did we're
walking Psalm 8513 says righteousness
goes before him and makes his footsteps
our path to follow so it is very
important Covenant keeping you've got to
know God know his Plan of Salvation know
his love then you've got to quit
rejecting his love and and open up your
heart and submit to God that means line
up under his authority recognize him as
your Sovereign Lord you have to yield to
the holy spirit's leading you got to be
filled with the Holy Spirit and yield to
the holy spirit's leading because Romans
8 11 through or 14-6 says only those led
by the spirit are the children of God so
we've got to in that passage It also
says the spirit is the spirit Spirit of
adoption there's no fear in this we cry
out ABA Papa father ABA father God so
Hebrews 8:10 God says the New Covenant
is this I will put my laws in their mind
write them on their hearts I will be
their God they shall be my people if you
love me Jesus said keep my Commandments
but God says it's not by power or might
it's by my my spirit so Covenant keeping
is living in a
constant Covenant relationship with the
Lord this is an intimate relationship
it's respecting his authority it's
walking in loyalty to his government of
love and works are merely an evidence
that we're living in Covenant
relationship amen praise God thank you
for the wonderful answer Shelly all
right brother Daniel here's your fourth
and final question why was God silent
all those years between the Old
Testament and New Testament that's from
Jacqueline in British Columbia all right
thank you Jacqueline for this question
there were about 400 years that passed
between the closing stories of the Old
Testament that would be the end of the
book of Nehemiah and then the beginning
of the gospels and people often refer to
that as the
intertestamental period and during that
400 years God was not silent
let me explain what I mean here today
the cannon of scripture in other words
the books of the Bible is closed there
are no new books being added to the
Bible today but God is still speaking
amen and the same is true during that
400 years there were no new Old
Testament books that were being added
but God was still speaking during that
time and I want to tell you how number
one God was speaking through his word uh
think about what Hebrews 1 verse1 says
God who at various times and in various
ways spoke in time past to the fathers
by the prophets the prophets in times
past had spoken and then take you on to
2 Timothy 3:16 Says that all scripture
is given by inspiration of God and is
profitable for Doctrine for Repro for
correction for instruction in
righteousness so those words of the
prophets after they were written was
still God speaking useful useful words
from God even after the Old Testament is
closed useful today and useful during
those 400 years now I want to share with
you another way other than the
continuing words of scripture another
way that God was speaking during those
400 years during those 400 years
Alexander the Great conquered the
Persian Empire in 334 BC and then
Alexander the Great died and his empire
was divided up into four parts under
four of his generals and then the Greek
Empire after that was little by little
replaced by Rome which rose up to
complete control what's the point of
this all of those events had been F had
been predicted in Bible prophecy from
The Book of Daniel chapter 2 and 7 and
chapter 8 and so as those things were
taking place that was God's word going
out and it does not return void the
Fulfillment of Prophecy that's God's
word was taking place during those 400
years even though there was nothing
ringing in someone's ears from a voice
shouting out and then number three God
was speaking to people individually and
I want you to think back to the time in
in the book of Exodus where it appeared
like God was silent while the people of
Israel were under slavery in Egypt in
Exodus 2: 24 and 25 it says so God heard
their groaning and God remembered his
Covenant with Abraham Isaac and Jacob
and God looked upon the children of
Israel and God acknowledged them to our
carnal ears uh without illumination on
everything in the background it seemed
like God had forgotten and now he's
finally remembering instead here's what
was really happening during that time
period God was prompting the hearts of
those Hebrew midwives shipon Pua in
Exodus chapter 1 God was prompting the
mind of Pharaoh's daughter to rescue
Moses god prompted Moses Moses's parents
to rescue him in Hebrews 11:23 says that
they did this as an Act of Faith in
other words they were responding to God
so what's going on God was talking to
individual people and during those 400
years the same thing was happening God
was not giving any new revelation
because everything that was necessary
had been given up to that point but
God's God was still speaking and he is
today no new books are being added now
no living prophets adding something to
the Bible but we've got everything God
said and our responsibility is to listen
up amen listen up I like that thank you
sir all right Pastor James I've got your
fourth and final question
Revelation 17:12 says the 10 horns which
you saw are 10 Kings who have receive no
kingdoms as yet but they receive
Authority for one hour as kings with the
Beast this whole passage from verses 9-
12 is very tricky to understand the part
I am trying to work out in my mind is
the one hour found in verse 12 this must
be prophetic because it would make no
sense otherwise
if this is prophetic and one day equals
one year how long is one prophetic hour
that's from Heather in Canada who texted
that to us great question Heather you
know biblically speaking we have at
least three options to choose from the
word our is being used here literally in
other words uh these horns receive
Authority for one literal hour or 60
Minutes number two uh a second option is
prophetic time as you've alluded to uh
is the hour to be understood as day for
a year prophetic time and that would be
15 literal days now according to
Revelation 10:7 there's no more
prophetic time post
1844 uh that's the longest time prophecy
uh when the longest time prophecy ends
so I wouldn't choose option number two
option number three the third option is
to understand this one hour figuratively
as a form of speech that describes the
arrival of a specific event for example
we might say my hour has finally come
does the bible use the word hour in this
way actually it does in many occasions
for example Jesus says in Luke
22:53 when I was daily with you in the
temple you stretched forth No Hands
against me but this is your hour and the
power of Darkness now Jesus spoke this
as he was being arrested his trial his
arrest his mocking his crucifixion and
the final death took more than a literal
hour 60 minutes and it definitely took
less than 15 days so this biblical use
of the term hour is talking figuratively
of the arrival of a certain time again
in John 2:4 Jesus said unto Heroman what
have I to do with thee mine hour is not
yet come speaking to his mother who
wanted him to turn to provide wine for
the guests at the wedding Feast because
the r wine had run out or John 4:23 but
the hour comes and now is when the true
worshippers shall worship the father in
spirit and Truth for the father seeks
such to worship him so all of these
Biblical verses are examples of a
figurative use of the term hour the hour
has come when the 10 Kings who've
received no kingdoms yet will receive
Authority as kings with the Beast the
hour to rule with the Beast has arrived
in other words the 10 Kings have
Authority for one hour or will have the
hour of authority to Reign his Kings
with the Beast and that hour is fast
approaching amen amen thank you very
much sir all right we're going to take a
short break to let you know how you can
participate in this program we'll be
right
back if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible
Q&A then tell your friends each Monday
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's holy word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand to have your questions
answered on a future program just email
them to us at bible QA
3abn.org 28
3975 that's 618 228
3975 be sure to include your name and
where you live and then watch the reaban
Bible Q&A for answers from God's
word all right thanks for coming back
you got some time for some final
thoughts sister Shell simple we love you
and we pray for you amen that's right
and no questions too small no questions
too big even if it's about
unicorns Pastor James wanted to just to
revisit the uh first question on the
sanctuary and the holy and most holy
place you know the Earthly Sanctuary was
just a it was a figure or a symbol or a
type and in it the priest ministered
first in the Holy place and then once a
year in the most holy place and Paul is
picking up on that Paul is earnestly
reasoning with his Hebrews his Jews and
he's trying to convince him them to make
this transition from the Earthly to the
Heavenly Paul is actually calling for in
verse 10 of Hebrews 9 a Reformation of
thought and practice regarding the
sanctuary and its services so he's say
saying basically look to this greater
and more perfect Tabernacle in heaven
look to the blood of Christ who has
inaugurated this heavenly reality with
his sacrifice his Point again is that
the Earthly Sanctuary has become has
come to an end and the Heavenly
Sanctuary is now the reality it was
typified in the Earthly Sanctuary where
the first began where the priest began
his work in the Holy place and then went
into the most holy Place Jesus Christ
too began his work in the Holy place and
then went into the mostly holy place and
this is confirmed in the Book of
Revelation where Jesus is pictured among
the candlesticks which is holy place in
Revelations churches and among the in
altar of incense which is holy place in
Revelation seals and I could go on and
on but Rick uh Ricky we're running out
of time so I'm going to hand it over to
you amen amen well thanks for joining us
everyone I know I've been blessed with
hearing what the word of God says and I
want to encourage you continue to study
God's word word hide it in your heart
God bless amen
[Music]